on this channel we've featured all sorts
of battles involving different kinds of
characters but we've never had one on
Old characters yet sure we've had some
videos on badass moments featuring old
characters or Showcases of power but
actual battles well that changes today
today I'm going to be sharing what I
think are some of the best fights
featuring old characters now take note
as usual there are going to be some
occasional spoilers as these fights
oftentimes take place deep into the
story
Whitebeard vs The Marine starts the list
and what an establishing moment it was
[Music]
amongst one piece characters Whitebeard
probably has the best reputation in case
for being the strongest character in the
cast with a character list that big
that's saying something isn't it but
this old man has more than proven his
worth countless times in the story he's
got some epic fights and all but there's
little that can beat how badass he
looked taking on the Marines it's a
foreboding moment for all the Marines
and while this fight isn't quite the
animation and special effects
Masterpiece a lot of modern one-piece
fights are it does make up for it with
how strong it made Whitebeard look it's
not quite Madara versus an army level in
terms of being methodical destruction
tanked and the fact that Whitebeard did
all this by pure physical strength it's
nothing short of amazing no devil fruit
and all heck he didn't even touch the
Marines it was such a boss moment when
he rejected all help and proceeded to do
all of this
Yoshimura versus the ccg is a similarly
cool fight
there's been a trend of One Versus many
battles so far hasn't it next in line is
Yoshimura taking on the ccg from Tokyo
Ghoul I haven't even featured Tokyo
Ghoul as much in my newer videos and I
think that the whole one-eyed owl
storyline is one of the more engaging
ones I've seen in the anime that largely
has to do with how in hindsight I looked
at Yoshimura and his relation with his
daughter and the one-eyed owl identity
so in this battle Yoshimura takes on the
form of the one-eyed out and battles the
ccg like the Whitebeard one this really
sold how strong Yoshimura is even at his
age despite being outnumbered he
masterfully parried and overcame
everything thrown at him even a wounded
Yoshimura continued being such a tough
vote to overcome and when he finally
fell at the rooftop he'd taken down and
injured a lot of the ccg along the way
the story is not over at that point but
yoshimura's badass Last Stand was he did
give us a show on the way out though
Toki takes on hosen in this entry
hosting may not be the most popular
Gintama villain being prominently
featured only in one Arc still he made
the most of the limited time in the
spotlight well I guess we should expect
nothing less than that from the former
yato King one who managed to stomp in
Toki in their first encounter it pretty
much had the battle won curb stomping in
Toki like he was nothing
not even Our Hero's second wind was
enough to prevent him from getting
struck and nearly crushed by this
retired badass
Hunter had more people involved and was
a more even Affair but if this second
series of connected fights doesn't show
how strongholson really is then I don't
know what will yeah I know he's not
utsuro tier overpowered but with the
insane durability and fighting prowess
current hosts and has people should
always get excited at the thought of
prime hosts and battling against
gintama's heavyweights even if that all
remains in the realm of fantasy
oh
Garo finds himself in a tough one
against the brothers bang and bomb
when Garo set off to hunt Heroes he
thought that he'd have it easy after all
it's been nothing but success for him as
every hero in his way ended up being
nothing but a small bump in the road
however his Rampage also attracted the
attention of bang and bomb and the two
forces finally Clyde just as Garo was in
the process of battling genos and
contrary to expectations the two
brothers were actually winning showing
off what they're capable of even in
their old age the two combined their
martial arts to attack Garo and prevent
him from getting any major attacks of
his own what he could do was to
momentarily Force the two to back off
before Phoenix man interrupted the fight
it's really a cool twist to see these
old men hold their own as well anyone
Savvy enough with the tropes and cliches
of anime would have thought that these
two would put up a fight before getting
brushed assigned by the villain that's
being pushed but they actually did well
and might as well have won this
encounter so they Define their status as
some of the strongest heroes in the
series
yeah
if you're liking these scenes of all
characters showing that they've still
got it you might want to drop a like on
the video also don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and check it out later
for more videos that you might enjoy now
this next one's a heartbreaker and yes
I'm definitely talking about Jiraiya
versus pain
now I've intentionally placed this one
here so it contrasts with the bang and
bomb fight or as the previous one
subverted expectations this ended up
following it to a t with Jiraiya biting
it in this encounter with pain but you
just have to watch it and see how good
the fight is and this is a fight that
proves that even if you know what's
gonna happen it's the execution and the
emotional Stakes that really matter this
is by far the perfect way for Jiraiya to
go we all knew he would pass the torch
to Naruto someday but we didn't know
that he'd have this amazing performance
to go with it after handily defeating
Conan Jiraiya proceeded to defeat
multiple panes one after another he
pulled out everything from his bag of
tricks and even looked like he was about
to overcome the odds and pull off a
miracle of course it wasn't to be but I
couldn't have asked for a better way to
go out for our favorite pervy Sage it's
one of the strongest moments in Naruto
and one that hits even harder for people
who've been following the journey ever
since
King Bradley vs scar is also a legendary
moment
foreign
despite how he looks King Bradley is a
grizzled veteran an old man who's been
through the worst one of the most
powerful characters in the whole of FMA
it's only fitting that he makes his last
stand against scar a survivor of the
genocide he instigated it was at this
point that wrath Found A Perfect final
opponent for him and their battle was
one to talk about Bradley at this point
was a shell of himself and was beginning
to deteriorate as the battle rages on
however he still proved to be more than
a match for Scar and despite the two
being presented as being on par such
Notions were thrown out the longer the
battle went on with King Bradley even
looking to be on a fast track to win the
battle outright things would take a turn
however but even in the most crucial
part of the fight even with his arms
blown off he still manages to take scar
along with him right after confirming
his philosophical convictions this is
King Bradley at the end of his life
still a total badass and a Powerhouse
that needed all sorts of plot to finally
be put down what a beast
um
Yamamoto versus yuha blew up the bleach
fan community
yeah
when the Thousand-Year blood War arcs
anime adaptation was confirmed bleach
fans were excited not only will they get
an adaptation of the series final Arc
they'll also be able to see some of the
most intense fights in the series in
anime form when the anime hit it more
than blew away all expectations extended
scenes a consistent tense atmosphere and
fights that more than surpassed their
manga counterparts case in point
Yamamoto versus yuha this is already one
of the high points in the first part of
the arc as we see the final
confrontation of the two leaders of the
warring factions it's also where we saw
yamamoto's Bankai unveiled after years
of anticipation but the fight we got in
the anime was even better amazing art
animation and music made the whole thing
feel a lot more tense and breathtaking
than the manga could
I gotta tell you it was perfect
perfect everything down to the last
minute details you really could feel the
impact and the love the anime team gave
to the series with this fight alone and
it's rightfully one of the best episodes
in the first core prompts to the anime
team for masterfully recreating this
fight and adding some more scenes like
the flashbacks of the old gote stuff
that we didn't get to see in the manga
foreign
will finish up the list pretty nicely
it's no secret that Hunter Hunter is one
of my favorite anime of all time that's
why it just feels right to feature
another Mentor swan song especially
after we had that Uriah moment earlier
nitero vs meruem in my opinion is the
highlight of the Chimera antarct as far
as fights go we could make a case with a
multiple times gone got to shine this up
but in terms of the actual fighting I
think it's this one that takes the cake
that's just how it is when two
characters were at the top of the totem
pole get pitted against each other
matero versus meruim was full of
spectacle with each fighter giving their
role in his death match as they should
do well I didn't think that nataro would
be able to defeat Maryland the way he
showed off his abilities in the fight
made a Believer out of millions of
Hunter Hunter fans that day the show
wasn't even hiding how meruen wasn't
even bothered by nataro's hardest
efforts but at least we've got a
memorable farewell out of it I think
this fight isn't as tear-jerking as the
dryer one just by hands with point being
that next to the Naruto one this one
definitely takes the cake as one of my
favorite mentor farewells
foreign
and that my friend is my top old man
fights in anime how about yours tell me
what your favorite old character fights
are in anime I'd love to hear your
thoughts so don't forget to drop by the
comment section for feedback or actually
you can drop by our social media with
all links provided in the description
box whatever the case and thank you for
watching this video I hope to see you
next time and I'll be waiting on you in
the next video